I've gathered it all then I'm gonna push
do you understand so you don't move it
at one and then at one you're going to
load the watch back foot is not allotted
then then I lock everything and then I
let it come out boom and the more that
you are wanting everything the less
you're going to learn you are closer you
are closer if if I don't move it all and
give us a move it off but he's he's like
inside his body
ok no don't look for these big things
just look for the drill
did I throw it up I smash it in let go
that's what we're getting
so I come for us I'm already in contact
I'm going to compress I'm already in the
punching try not to hit him try not to
make him move I have this same drill
his energy comes in and I try to send it
to my feet do you see how much more
movement he's getting out of me watch me
do the other one cuz I'm not training
I'm being sloppy here he goes he's a
movement out of me as I locked my body
so if you lock your body you not gonna
swish and sway
you're not gonna Bend and the energy
you're going to shoot it down to the
ground you got it got it okay
they try like that he's pushing and I'm
doing that he's also going to be locked
so he's gonna change the drill okay I
hear he goes yeah right head towards it
all here he goes
I lock everything out same thing
oh he'll move all of me so he's locked
out he pushes you go down he goes boom I
go down so again right like heavy Oh
oh my hands are hurt or lie
I think this stroke I'm going to change
the tiny comes in see how I let
him come in he falls into it and then I
don't push him back he just hits the
ground you understand
so here was here was the other one right
he pushes and I let them come in and
then on projection out I see how you
could hide it in the looking under hand
this time you comes into me and I just
let him hit the ground
come on
but you can see what why did he do that
was it like something hot on the floor
was the top right he's not just walking
through there's a second where he hits
boom so his body's just being his
balance is taken boom right on the on
the ground so let's do a EQ all right
we're here and how many notice on the
slow-motion portions of the technique
there's that part there's not it doesn't
look like this there's this there's a
second where boom
most what did you do hmm he's hitting
that background so you can you can
experiment for it
from the other
well what happened in that spot to rest
what because what you do on the she
crashed on the first one so they don't
there's anyone you absorbed it in your
arm okay you don't absorb it you want to
land right here you want to push it you
want to fly